to celebrate
120 years of outstanding accomplishment
by balcony University
but also
the conclusion of your amazing tenure as
president of this University the amario
baconi has always had a European
vocation
since its foundation bocconi's goal is
to raise
new generations of European leaders
and you dear Mario
you have renewed and realized this
European vocation over and over
you made baconia founding member of
chivika the European network of social
science universities
you helped bocconi to attract
students from over 100 different nations
you have given almost 60 years of your
life and your work to bocconi
and the results are there for all to see
this is your legacy dear Mario
it is the bright future of these
students here in this room and outside
and one of the whole bocconi family that
is your legacy
and I have been so lucky to have you
Mario
as an advisor and as a friend
in all these three years that I spent at
the helm of the European Commission
I benefited a lot from your advice as an
academic
but of course also from your experience
as a former prime minister of Italy
throughout your career
you have straw have strived to keep
Italy at the heart of Europe
and you have made Italy's voice heard
and respected
in all European capitals
you have always been a link
between the North
and the south of Europe
and I've often heard you explain that
Europe is strong
when Italy is strong
and vice versa
you have been an advocate
and an architect of reforms here in
Italy
to modernize the country
to strengthen its place as Europe's
second largest industrial power
and at the same time you have been an
advocate
and architect of reforms in Europe too
because you have always believed
that Europe had to change
to keep Pace with the changing world
grazia Mario
[Applause]
as European commissioner you were a
guardian of free and Fair competition
and of course of our single Market
as prime minister we heard it you
stabilized the Italian economy
and in parallel you started calling for
change in the European Union economic
governance
you have always stressed The crucial
link between Investments on one hand and
reforms on the other hand and to put it
in your words
public Investments are the fuel of
economic growth
but reforms are the engine
and this philosophy has been our Guiding
Light throughout these years of pandemic
and War
today I would like to mention three
examples
on how the right mix of Investments and
reforms
is moving Europe forward
let me begin with Next Generation EU
Next Generation EU our 800 billion euros
plan to boost and modernize Europe's
economy after the pandemic
the Next Generation EU and Italy is a
perfect match
Italy is receiving more than 190 billion
euros for Investments and reforms
almost 67 billion euros have already
been handed over to Italy
and their impact is starting to be very
visible
I know for example
that bocconi and the three other
universities in Milan
have just launched a project
called Musa
for urban regeneration
funded by Next Generation EU
you are mobilizing 700 researchers and
joining forces
with 20 private companies from the
energy sector
to the pharmaceutical sector and to the
chips industry
and together you will Design
the city of the future
powered by Clean Energy
and with clean transport for all
that will host high-tech companies and
create new well-paying jobs
so I am very proud that Europe is
investing in such an ambitious and good
project
besides unprecedented Investments
Next Generation you has also promoted
some crucial reforms
one of them is the reform of public
administration
and I know that some professors from
bocconi have been closely involved in
this in the its Inception thank you very
much for that
but also reforms to reduce for example
late payments
or bureaucracy for small companies
or reforms to accelerate procedures for
renewable energy and I'll come back to
that later
as you say Mario reforms are the engine
of Italy's economy
they can really boost the recovery
my second point
is on investment and reforms
to make energy more affordable
Italy is one of the countries that was
hit the hardest
by Russia's gas blackmail
Putin has cut its export of pipeline gov
to Europe
by 80 percent in only eight months
but we have managed to compensate
and to diversify
and Italy makes a perfect example
you used to import 40 of your gas from
Russia
and now that share is down to roughly 10
percent
thanks to an impressive effort to
diversify your supply
Europe storages
were filled by 96 percent at the
beginning of November
so with all these measures we're safe
for this winter
but of course this comes at a tough
price and that is the price of energy
and therefore in parallel
we have worked on a set of measures to
bring down the prices
we have
insisted
on a solidarity contribution
on the extra profits of energy companies
it will generate roughly 4 billion euros
in revenues here in Italy already in
2023
it is money to support vulnerable
households and vulnerable businesses
we are also working on a joint purchase
of gas because if we go to the markets
to buy gas it is much better we go as 27
we have much more Market power than by
going individual and driving up the
prices like that so we can get better
prices with joint purchase
and we have proposed the so-called
Market correction mechanism which is
basically a price cap
Italy has demanded it from the very
beginning thank you Italy for that
it will prevent
excessive spice hikes
price hikes it will cut manipulation
and what will cut speculation
and as we speak right now member states
are discussing on how to make it fit for
all of the European Union I'm very
confident will have it in place before
the end of the year
but now
we must focus on the next winter
not this one he was safe for this winter
but the next year and the next winter
there is still a gap to be filled
but the good news is the reassuring news
in a very difficult story is that we
have the potential but it is just
untapped
and this potential is renewable energy
this year we have achieved the largest
growth in renewable energy in the
history of the European Union
50 additional gigawatts
which is double of what we had added
last year
and we could accelerate even more it's
not figures from the European commission
but the International Energy agency that
tells us
that we could replace another 14 billion
cubic meter of Russian gas already next
year
if we are speeding up the renewable
projects the renewable energy these
projects are ready to go
but they are stuck because of slow
permitting so we have therefore just
passed a new emergency regulation to
immediately unblock renewable energy
projects now
because ladies and gentlemen my dear
friend renewable energy is not only good
for the climate climate and for the
planet yes it is good for that
but renewable energies are also good for
our independence because they are
homegrown
and they are affordable compared to
fossil fuel fossil fuels are much more
expensive than renewable energy so let's
go for the clean and independent version
of energy and this is renewable energy
I think we should work now together on
the necessary reforms to accelerate the
green transition
Italian families do need clean and
affordable energy
and Italian industry also need clean and
affordable energy
and therefore let's have a look at the
business sector
Italy is home to some of the most
Innovative companies small and
medium-sized
so the industrial basis is strong
but the cost of energy
is heavily Weighing on them
and the only sustainable way out as
we've just discussed discussed is the
transition to renewable energy that is
not only affordable but homegrown but
this transition from fossil fuels to
renewable energy takes time
and the global competition is getting
tougher
as you know
the United States has just presented a
massive investment plan
into the clean tech sectors
the so-called inflation reduction Act
I must say first of all it is good that
the United States is joining us in
decarbonizing their economy that's good
it matters
because the United States is the second
largest emitter in the world
but
the inflation reduction act can also
create distortions
by for example privileging U.S firms
it is the buy American logic that
underpins part of the IRA
it is tax breaks that could lead to
discrimination and it is production
subsidies that could discriminate
European companies
so we have to address this
and this is why we are thinking about
three different lines how to nurture our
clean tech industry
the first point is against the backdrop
I just described that we have to adjust
our own state aid rules
we have to make it simpler for public
investment to power the transition
our stated rules exist for a very good
reason and you would know it better than
you dear Mario you have been
commissioner for competition
so you know it that it is necessary that
they have to make sure that companies
from all member states can compete on
equal footing inside the single Market
however now we have to take a fresh look
this includes for example how we can
make our state aid Frameworks more
predictable
and more simple and faster
or how we can support the whole value
chain
down to the mass production of the most
strategic green text Solutions
and clean end products
so lots of strategic work to do
but
we also know that not all member states
have the same capacity to invest in
their budgets in strategic sectors and
this is my second point
not all member states have the fiscal
space for state aid so we need
complementary European financing to
Foster this clean tech across the whole
European Union
and this is where repower EU comes into
play
repower you is our new plan to overcome
our energy dependency on Russia
repower EU would mean 9 billion euros in
clean energy Investments for Italy
I have now proposed to further boost we
power EU to accelerate the clean
transition all across the European Union
that's a short term
in the midterm
we need a structural solution for our
clean tech industry
the goal of our European policy is
for European industry to be leaders
world leaders in the clean transition
so this is why I introduced the idea of
establishing a sovereignty fund
the logic behind it is very simple
if we have a common European industrial
policy
this requires a common European funding
so here too
this is about strategic decisions
that would allow us to maintain Global
Leadership
and my third point is that we are very
closely working with the Biden
Administration right now on the most
concerning aspects of the IRA
and this concludes for example that we
have joined efforts
on several clean tech sectors
where we Face together the same
challenges
we face for example the challenge
together
that we are developing an over
dependency on China
if it is about raw materials that are
critical for our green transition
so one of the possible solutions could
be to create
a raw materials Club
to overcome China's Monopoly in this
field
we have a lot of good work ahead of us
but important is the message
that one thing is for sure
the US and the European Union
We Stand stronger
individually
When We Stand Together collectively
ladies and gentlemen
my final Point has to do with the reform
of our economic governance
you have worked so much on this Mario
so I'm glad that we have delivered a new
proposal
which I think resonates with everything
dear Mario
that you have been saying for almost 10
years now
we have listened very carefully
you've always said that the future of
our children
needs both
that we invest in sustainability
but also that we invest sustainably
and this is why we want to give National
governments more flexibility on their
debt reduction path
to open the space for strategic
Investments
the Mastery targets do not change
what changes is how we get there
there will be a common European
framework
in which member states will design a
plan
on how to achieve a gradual reduction of
public debt
where Investments and reforms will go
hand in hand
there will be more freedom to invest
but also more scrutiny on the process
once the plan has been agreed and thus
tougher implementation
with this proposal
we could move past a Whole Decade
of divisive debates on our economic
governance in the European Union
it is an economic government that
governance that works for Europe
because it works for all member states
and I believe
dear Mario
that this is also what you have always
strived for throughout your entire
career
roughly one year ago you said
Europe is trying to find a new balance
between sustainability
reforms
and investment to support demand end of
quote
and I'm so grateful for your
contribution dear Mario to finding this
balance
I know that you will leave as your
legacy a new Research Center on European
policy right here at bocconi and I'm
sure
it will become an important resource in
our work at the commission
and I will still count
on your advice my dear friend in the
years to come we're speaking on a
regular basis
I have the questions you have the
precious advice for me
Europe needs your wisdom
Europe needs your capacity
to build Bridges
to build Bridges between Academia
and politics
as always between the North and the
South
but also reaches between the
difficulties of the present
and the brighter future for all
so ladies and Gentlemen please join me
in congratulating a great Italian
a great Economist and a great European
grazia
[Applause]
[Music]